we have predators on our streets how
could he really be a progressive and
want to lock these people up and I'd say
lock the SOPs up increase the penalties
increase them I would put the son of a
gun in jail
what bad dude death joe biden became the
presumptive Democratic nominee in the
2020 election by running as a moderate
unifier hoping to win over voters with
the promise of a return to business as
usual politics from the pre Trump era
consensus is not a weakness I did a
senator it's what I did is your vice
president working with Barack Obama what
I will do as your president now we can
find some fringe folks libertarians and
left-wingers in my party who say no
that's not we should do but politically
that consensus been arrived at
now the Cova 19 pandemic has led him to
rethink his platform of a return to the
days of bipartisan consensus seizing the
opportunity to offer bold change on
issues like climate change health care
social welfare and infrastructure but
it's worth remembering that in his 44
years in the Senate and then his Vice
President Biden repeatedly took
advantage of moments of crisis to push
through policies that have exacerbated
some of the most critical problems
afflicting American society crime bill
hell we've got crime bills coming out
our ears the president says he wants to
wage a war on drugs but if that's true
what we need is another d-day not
another Vietnam President Bush did not
last out precipitously in Iraq after
9/11 at each pivotal moment he's chosen
a course of moderation in the
deliberation and I believe he will
continue to do so just to set the record
straight almost the same thing that got
passed the Patriot Act was introduced by
me in 1994
four women accused him of inappropriate
behavior several women have accused
Biden of inappropriately touching them
in public and now his campaign is in
crisis because of a sexual assault
allegation by a former staffer another
person has come forward to support Tara
Reid's allegations against Joe Biden if
they believe Tara Reid they probably
shouldn't vote for me I wouldn't vote
for me if I believe Tara Reid women
should be believed but the terrible
choice put forth by the two major
parties in 2020 isn't just about sexual
misconduct or character Joe Biden's
greatest political liability is his
legacy as a lawmaker and vice president
a legacy that laid the groundwork for
the Trump administration's most
draconian policies on crime drugs civil
liberties surveillance immigration and
foreign policy Biden's record serves as
a cautionary tale about bipartisanship
and bold thinking in response to
perceived crises going all the way back
to the 70s a literal epidemic of rape in
this country every major crime bill
since 1976 every minor crime bill has
had the name of the Democratic senator
from the state of Delaware Joe Biden i
sat next to Strom Thurmond and became
friends with Strom Thurmond together we
passed a crime bill so don't tell me you
can't work with people on compliment in
the 80s Biden worked on several bills
with the former segregationist that
established mandatory minimum sentences
raised maximum sentences and effectively
created the modern system of civil asset
forfeiture which allows authorities to
seize the money and property of the
accused without charging them with a
crime whoa where's all this from the
government can take everything you own
everything from your car to your house
your bank account you can take
everything you got a gun you commit a
felony ten years we already have it five
years minimum mandatory judge can't say
you know you had it in your pocket you
never intended to use it we're only
gonna give you one year judge has to say
five years
well he wants to make it 10 or 20 or 60
I we can work that out he wanted to
remove judicial discretion for those who
quote don't meet the middle class
criteria of susceptibility to
rehabilitation they are beyond the pale
many of those people they literally have
not been socialized it doesn't matter
whether or not they're the victims of
society the end result is they're about
to knock my mother on the head with a
lead pipe shoot my sister beat up my
wife taken on my sons so I don't want to
ask what made them do this they must be
taken off the street they are in jail
away from my mother
your husband our families the Biden
Thurmond Violent Crime Control Act of
1991 would have increased the maximum
sentence for 44 crimes to include the
death penalty wagon the newspaper
recently wrote Biden has made it a
death-penalty offense for everything but
jaywalking Republicans one-upped Biden
by adding 46 capital crimes I'm gonna
make it for forty six crimes Biden says
make it for 51 we're gonna get tough so
he proposed 53 then he presented the
final version of the legislation 60 new
death penalties brand-new 60 there are
70 additional enhancements of penalties
ie you go to jail longer after his
disastrous 1987 presidential campaign
Biden had staged his political comeback
in part by becoming a media darling on
issues of policing and crime and he led
the fight to pass the landmark 1994
crime bill under Bill Clinton when I
wrote the original bill that started
this whole process the so-called Biden
crime bill I didn't call a liberal Kampf
AB and write it I didn't call any big
society people and write it I call the
cops
a Democratic president 100,000 cops a
Democratic president that's the secret
that somehow the Republicans tried to
make the crime bill tougher I say
poppycock they didn't make anything
tougher I wrote that bill
he convinced Republicans to support
urban community programs as a way to
keep inner-city kids away from
respectable families I started looking
at found out at this midnight basketball
and get them together a bunch of jive
folks who are black white and Spanish
living in their city to do you know try
to see if they can be Michael Jordan
when they found out and we're keeping
schools open so gangs come off streets
instead of out raping my mother
marauding me robbing the local store
they're in a gymnasium and my daughter
will be safer my wife will be safer my
mother will be safer and I will be safer
and I will be happy never again should
Washington put politics and party above
law and order along with several laws
passed in the 80s the 1994 crime bill
drove up the local state and federal
prison populations and it tarnished the
reputations of Biden and Bill Clinton
who signed it into law
when Biden ran for president in 2008 he
told the New York Times that he knew
more people would be locked up across
the board but that it would drive down
crime in fact crime rates were already
falling when Biden pushed for the
passage of the 94 crime bill and they
have continued falling as the prison
population has declined in recent years
you ashamed of that bill not at all in
fact I drafted the bill we had enormous
success
the mass incarceration created by
Biden's la cama policies ripped apart
vulnerable communities and families for
a generation and the federal funding
streams and law-enforcement
infrastructure it created continue to
hinder reform efforts there are things I
would change but by enlarge what it
really did it restored American cities
[Music]
America is under attack literally under
attack by an enemy who is well financed
well supplied and well armed and fully
capable of declaring total war against a
nation and his people we have to hold
every drug user accountable in the 1980s
and 90s Biden was a prominent figure in
the bipartisan war on drugs today
there's a new epidemic smokeable cocaine
this is crack cocaine
it's as innocent-looking as candy but
it's turning our cities into battle
zones and it's murdering our children in
his first primetime address to the
nation from The Oval Office in 1989
President George HW Bush announced a
major escalation of the drug war an
assault on every front
we need more prisons more jails more
courts more prosecutors quite frankly
the president's plans not tough enough
bold enough or imaginative enough to
meet the crisis at hand Biden made it
clear that Democrats were just as tough
on drugs as Republicans he even
suggested that state and local officials
eradicate marijuana fields themselves
we're gonna have to worry about getting
governor's to go out in the
mountainsides with flamethrowers with
you next to them dealing with it in
their backyards during the period of
bloodshed and mayhem of which the
president has spoken we passed the law
bipartisan we said crack cocaine is such
a bad deal
but if you find someone with this much
of it a quarters worth not in value in
size five years in jail Biden had
co-sponsored the anti-drug Abuse Act of
1986 which meted out the same mandatory
minimum prison term to someone
possessing five grams of crack cocaine
as to someone possessing 500 grams of
powder cocaine five years no probation
no parole if you have this much lock him
up and put him in our prison he
continued pushing to create the office
of the drug czar after President Ronald
Reagan had vetoed his first legislative
attempt and advocated locking up young
drug offenders and quote military-style
boot camp prisons boot camps for
youthful offenders under this bill we
can string up barbed wire we can build
Quonset huts and we can put them in boot
camps we can do that
[Music]
[Applause]
in 2002 Biden introduced the rave act or
the reducing Americans vulnerability to
ecstasy act he argued that ecstasy abuse
among teenagers was skyrocketing and
that it was time to pass legislation he
had long planned I've been fighting to
get these club drugs changed in schedule
for years DEA was my opposition the rave
act not only increased penalties for
drug crimes it went after anyone who
owned the property where people did
drugs
that's the scum who should be put in
jail not just the guy selling the pills
arrest the promoter find a rationale
unrelated to drugs you don't have to get
him for drugs
turn off the water I put you in jail I
put you in jail the law expanded
authorities power to classify venues as
crack houses a provision that federal
prosecutors are now using to stop cities
from opening overdose prevention sites
I'm the guy who authored the crack house
legislation we can use the crack house
legislation to tear down these buildings
you can literally bulldoze down their
business great big bulldozer bull doze
it down literally not figuratively Biden
also lamented not being able to force
press outlets to stick to the
government's messaging about drugs hold
our media accountable is something we
all desire but there's a thing called
the First Amendment which is read in a
way that I think is a little excessive
in 2008 Biden began to recant on some of
his past stances on drugs and crime as
vice president he pushed for the 2010
Fair Sentencing Act which reduced but
did not eliminate the crack cocaine
sentencing disparity he had helped usher
into law after 21 years of studying
reviews these facts have convinced me
that the 101 disparity cannot be
supported but as Biden prepares to
confront new perceived drug crises
reformers are still struggling to unwind
many of the consensus policies he has
worked to enact in the war on drugs was
a big mistake who's made it has trapped
an entire generation
we disagree with the president's
decision to cut the custom service the
Coast Guard and the Border Patrol we
think we should do more to stem the flow
of drugs across our borders in 1996
Biden boasted about the additional
resources his crime bill had funneled to
border security agencies and argued for
sending the military to the Mexican
border to deal with drug trafficking
there ain't enough customs agents to
collect enough today Biden mocks Trump
for using the military at the border
he said that calls to build the wall are
divorced from reality and won't stop the
flow of illegal narcotics or human
smugglers though all the bad things are
coming through ports of entry right now
we don't need a wall but leading up to
his 2008 presidential campaign he said
this I voted for defense related to
drugs
you can offense will stop twenty kilos
of cup of cocaine coming through that
fence it will not stop someone climbing
over there around him Biden was
referring to the 2006 secure Fence Act
signed by george w bush which didn't
tamp down the drug trade or border
crossings but did forced migrants
further into increasingly dangerous
routes and remote desert areas which
according to the ACLU contributed to
thousands of deaths President Obama I
think did a heck of a job to compare him
to what what this guy is doing is
absolutely out fine
Biden now condemns the Trump
administration's tactics of enforcement
and deportation the most vulnerable the
undocumented how are we made better or
stronger as a nation when immigrant and
Latino communities live in a daily
terror that of a nice raid on their
workplace this is heartbreak you know a
heartbreaking it's the very definition
of being counterproductive but in 1996
he voted for a law that increased
detentions and expedited removals for
immigration related offenses largely
creating the current approach
during Biden's years as vice president
the federal government took full
advantage of the infrastructure and
expanded powers the law had established
and the Obama administration deported a
record number of people you called me
deported see that I thought we lay the
groundwork for passing comprehensive
immigration reform took too much too
long to get it right and the President
did get it right by daca as well as
making sure that it tried to protect
parents as well
and by the way moving on an immigration
bill as well but that bill failed so the
best biting can do today is promised
that he won't use the deportation
machinery he helped create and that
presidents from both major parties have
employed during so-called border and
immigration crises at least temporarily
the first hundred days of my
administration no one no one will be
deported at all law enforcement today
faces terrorist bombing like we've never
seen in our history as a nation in 1995
Biden had introduced a bill that
combined all of his ideas for growing
the surveillance state civil
libertarians were opposed to it you guys
tried to help get it passed including
the wiretap changes in the rest though
it floundered four years after 9/11
Congress rushed through an amended
version of that legislation with
overwhelming bipartisan support you can
ask the Attorney General list because I
got a call when he introduced a Patriot
Act he said Joe I'm introducing the act
basically as you wrote it in 1994 this
bill met with an overwhelming
overwhelming agreement in Congress he
had laid the groundwork for a sweeping
surveillance law that allowed the
federal government to carry out criminal
prosecutions based on secret evidence
and to detain even US citizens
indefinitely without due process
this new law that I signed today will
allow surveillance of all communications
used by terrorists including emails the
internet and cell phones to let the FBI
agents buy weapons as powerful as the
drug cartels add up continuing his
decades-long effort to militarized
domestic law enforcement in the fight
against drugs and terror
Biden had added a provision to the
Patriot Act allowing state and local
police to obtain federal funding for
special equipment to combat terrorism
there is a strong likelihood that Iraqis
who welcomed us as liberators Biden
played a key role in helping the Bush
administration build support for other
elements of its disastrous post 9/11
agenda including toppling Saddam Hussein
there is an emerging pattern that
convenience may throw him into the arms
of al Qaeda so must be dealt with he
must be dealt with if you turned on now
and the television showed aircraft
striking Baghdad it would not be a
pre-emptive attack
there's nothing pre-emptive about its in
enforcement Biden teamed with John
McCain to defeat an amendment that would
have prevented Bush from going to war
unless he got approval from the UN
Security Council the UN will conclude if
we don't America will so we better he is
still harboring and he is still seeking
the accumulation of weapons of mass
destruction that case I believe has been
made today Biden has attempted to recast
his boat to authorize military force in
Iraq claiming that he trusted President
Bush to use that power only to pressure
Saddam into allowing weapons inspections
the rationale was that's the way to not
go to war because I didn't believe he
had those nuclear weapons I didn't
believe you had those weapons of mass
destruction former Bush and Obama
administration defense secretary Robert
Gates wrote in 2014 that Biden quote has
been wrong on nearly every major foreign
policy and national security issue over
the past four decades I did not believe
this is a rush to war I believe it's a
march to peace and security I've learned
one thing since I've decided to run for
president and I assume one thing
everything about me everything about me
is going to come out in the public
record and I've done some dumb things
I'll do dumb things again Joe Biden is
again opportunistically changing his
political approach in response to a
high-profile threat and is preparing to
remake himself as an economic populist
who will bring transformative change
through federal legislation
this is what leaders have to lead and
governments have to work this is going
to take bold creative federal action
this will go down as one of those
progressive administration's in American
history the younger generation now tells
me how tough things are give me a break
no no I have no empathy chorus give me a
break because here's the deal guys we
decided we were going to change the
world and we did we did in 2020 voters
may feel obligated to choose the lesser
evil but they should be under no
illusions about what a Biden presidency
would mean Trump keeps saying that his
words he's a wartime president start to
act like one an avatar of the political
establishment for over four decades
Biden has repeatedly taken advantage of
critical moments in history to help lead
us to disastrous Foreign Wars police
militarization warrantless surveillance
border walls and mass incarceration use
your full authority this is a war
act like a commander-in-chief use it all
[Music]